hello everyone welcome to part nine of
my resident evil 8 gameplay where
the only way i can go is here i'm pretty
sure
um which means i'm going to fight the
wolf i wasn't
positive you'd be able to do it so i'm
just going to save right here and see if
we actually can do it
um but based on the note this guy had
telling me to get this weapon i think i
probably
can it's interesting it's like two sort
of boss fights
in very close proximity to one another
here
um so my loadout
right now even though this is the newest
shotgun i have a preference for this
shotgun
because it can have a
bigger clip um which i feel like is
going to help me in this kind of
situation
um i'm assuming that the next level that
i or the next area i get to will have a
new gun and i'll sell one of these at
some point
but uh we're going with this shotgun
there's one bullet on that okay i'm just
gonna shortcut this
no i'll have that equipped maybe we do
have
a bunch of rifle rounds so
okay i'm gonna keep this boy
to there this one for now is going to go
over here
and then i will have this equipped
just to get out what i can actually let
me see if i can
craft anything i cannot and we'll see if
we can even fight him at all
if we can't that is okay
hey buddy big scary west boy
would you like to call say hi
hello my friend that maybe i should
start with a sniper rifle no this seems
like the best choice
it's just that it's going to run out of
emma real [ __ ] quick
handsome man hello
my best friend
oh there he is hey big boy you wanna you
trying to trying to [ __ ] hang out
all right i'm gonna shoot just ahead of
you
smoke didn't help me so much there oh
he's jumpy
oh cool [ __ ] i should have reloaded
[ __ ] i didn't think to reload
that's a problem it's gonna be a problem
for me it's gonna be a real problem for
me
boom [ __ ] reload reload reload reload
just use all of these as fast as i can
right
uh did i miss him [ __ ] dude damn it
okay one more
and then just ahead of them this all
seems good
sniper
[Applause]
surely that's not it that's it
oh that was a really good strategy
i thought that i'd have to swap to the
shotgun and then like
oh cool what do you got for me
oh it's beautiful
wow all right great
i expected that to be way hotter i don't
know why i was expecting dark souls
but i was
okay mitt i have a beast
let me sell you i need to make my webcam
smaller again
so that i can just read that
beautiful yup sell it
your coin and then
i was trying to upgrade everything my
logic with um
upgrading both shotguns is you get more
money when you sell them
um i don't imagine they're ever gonna
give me another sniper rifle
but we'll upgrade that for now
do what we can and i don't think i can
buy
any explosive ammo
yet still don't care about mines maybe i
will at one point but
not today sir okay well let's do that
then
that's right it's here reload speed
great way easier than i expected again
um okay
um so i think that we're going to what
is this name
mordo i believe
and i still can't get through
the door that's that's there so yeah
this seems like the right way to go
what the [ __ ] oh my god
hey shitlord
i don't know oh my god but that's why
this shotgun i have a preference for
even though it's not as strong
that ammo capacity the room got lighter
what were they blocking out the lights
somehow
how would they do with that uh where is
the cam fluid
okay cool great
um i've been in this house before
haven't i also i think there was two of
them that i just missed something
did he have the camp fluid on him and i
just didn't see it
um yeah all right
so where to go from here is going to be
still more this way i think
and then this way
if that's a sign of what's ahead
i don't love it for me i'm not a huge
fan
that's oh my what the [ __ ] oh
it's a windmill i thought it was some
kind of giant
okay
this place is going to be ugly see at
least the dollhouse was pretty this
one's going to just be
trash home i imagine i have to shoot
through that slime
what the [ __ ] was that what the [ __ ] was
that
was that red thing did i just imagine
that surely that was a real thing what
the [ __ ] was that
also i should be using handgun am i
no maybe not um was it part of this
i don't know what just happened
ethan what are you acting like why is
that that hard would you something
happen to your hands buddy
okay
you're fine coward
didn't expect this to be something i'd
be doing in resident evil
in 2021 but here i am
gotta get both here i'm sorry i don't
love it either but for some reason the
large man with the stall i knows how to
make
potions i'm not really sure how it works
either don't ask me
get your ass out here coward
face death head on cheeple
i don't know what that's supposed to
mean okay great
thank you both kindly laboratory
i might have friends at the laboratory
is this where i'm gonna get this
finally okay this looks
small so my guess
is that oh i thought it was going to
give me hubs
oh it's another one of the labyrinths um
well maybe this is also a good
indication yeah
i was gonna say i think it's gonna take
me underground and by the looks of
things
it certainly is which you know
i'm not a huge fan of but um i don't
know that i'm a huge fan of
really any of the options this game has
presented me
i think i will thank you we can take the
this one
we already have the village one love to
see it
love to see it thank you yeah all right
good [ __ ]
i would not be [ __ ] getting in an
elevator in this place let me tell you
you know what i wouldn't do that [ __ ] no
dude
you want me to get an elevator in this
building is it because it's a loading
screen because otherwise
there's no [ __ ] way photo of a rare
animal so that was a pig
i don't know if you've seen a pit oh i
did get all of them though didn't i oh
yeah i can't get rid of these
oh i like the sound of match
i was actually assuming based on both
this being like resident evil 4
and what's happened so far that the duke
would be what would give me a weapon in
this place that i'll find him somewhere
here
and that's where i would get a new gun
which i am
um i mean i don't know what it'll be but
i will trade
one of my shotguns in for it i've got
everything here i do
great let's [ __ ] go
okay i expect ethan to lose his hand a
little bit but he didn't his hands are
fine
happy about it
okay this seems
unsafe this seems
like a hazard
feel like you need building inspection
to check on
all of this cool
great no this is fine this is actually
very fun for me
okay cool all right let's do that i
don't know what kind of enemies are
gonna be down here
hmm we have options this isn't gonna
open of course not
[ __ ] resident evil [ __ ]
garbage okay
cool labyrinth puzzle
oh is that example beneath it it is
the six wing unborn key that means i'm
gonna get that down here
didn't expect that
that's the one i can't get into then
okay
so there's something for me to do
now here then
all right great now i love this it's
like until dawn
when's the first jump scare going to be
you know just i can't wait it's going to
be so much fun i'm going to [ __ ] myself
huh okay
cool oh okay so that's a lot of sounds
yep a lot of sounds happening
is that a radio also
what's the purpose of all this you just
who hung that
that there and why
[ __ ] what's this somebody live here
[Music]
exciting
great
is that the old lady is that my witch
friend or is that someone mean
[Music]
you [ __ ] simp that's what we call a
[ __ ] sip i'll just be taking this
what what what what are you doing with
mother's
special choice it's literally my first
what do you mean mother's special child
father
what's her baby back don't screw with me
wait wait please please if you take it
let me laugh at me
he is a [ __ ] simp but
which i just would like to be played
you're
stupid you talk to me okay i take back
everything i said
it's all over the way
[Music]
was that all a game
[ __ ] i can just shoot through it though
in it so
she's probably damn freak not a problem
i was a bit mean ethan i was just gonna
say for the record i think simp is just
generally a term that we use for just
when someone's nice to a woman
and i think it's a bit [ __ ] you know
cool song dude
i also sing when i'm nervous
i'm so torn on kind of liking him but
then also think he's
he's like a [ __ ] bag because he called
me stupid and said i talk too much
that reminds me of uh the dates i went
on in high school
it's actually the opposite of me
realistically i was not talkative in
high school
it was well maybe my later years is this
the content you came here for
damn why is this so red though you know
like i'm gonna come back i'm gonna come
back it's fine
it's fine
is this the entrance oh what the [ __ ]
what what
i mean i got what i wanted
hmm interesting
okay this is all very peaceful and i'm
[ __ ] suspicious
okay yeah
yep i will take whatever's in here
please
thank you
that's the boat
interesting um okay
what you got for me king nothing
apparently
there's literally nothing in here there
we go all right leave the boat key in
the shack in the mine
hans is dead so no more fishing for a
while i mean we all know his death was
no accident he was eaten by a giant fish
boat and all
i don't know that they needed to make
that note that explicit
i feel like you could have danced around
maybe like a little bit with that one
um all right
am i going to have to come back here
i continue to assume so i'm upset that
that's red
i have to because of the the key
it's fine oh
that's right he said he left it in the
mine um
that part i should appreciate more for
being explicit
we'll see if we can go anywhere this way
first no we cannot
no okay back to the mic looking for
a vote key
hmm okay
i feel like oh oh gwenty thing oh my i
get so excited whenever i spot one
because i think they always gonna be the
resume before
excuse me mate
oh thank you
um all right i'm
the staircase is the only option
i believe so let's
go
oh don't mind if i do all right
it's gonna be shoot that you want me to
shoot it
or you want me to touch it
well that's the most [ __ ] convenient
thing in the world
video games are ridiculous okay
[ __ ] sounds in here man
beautiful
is there something swimming in here is
that what i'm hearing
oh
oh my was that a person
oh they're lichens okay
let me just see what else is up before i
come [ __ ] with you
but this shotgun does make me
pretty confident overall
dewey is that it
okay come at me
if you become closer it's easier for me
give it a shot
come on come at me
and i have to reload for days
cool except right there shut him in the
way
music's gone interesting
okay i i wondered if there'd be a
different enemy type down here
um because i get that something about
morrow
is sort of fish themed
you know the the whole boat thing
the fact that there's a note about
fishing the entire water-based situation
that we find ourselves in
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] who are you who's this
big dick player oh it's one of these
okay
yeah yeah i see you i see you i'm not
that scared of you now though oh [ __ ]
it's all right you can get a bit close
jesus dude
oh no oh oh i'm pressing lb instead of
all b
a lot of notes okay let me maybe get
some ground
oh there's more of them oh there's more
of them oh great okay
didn't i just say oh only two of them
well um not my favorite thing that's
ever happened
should i get out a pipe bomb
[Applause]
at the very least it's funny
how are you still alive just die
oh thank you that was very kind of you
thank you i appreciate that a lot
that really meant a lot to me and now
i'm [ __ ] out of [ __ ] ammo
i do like this shotgun but people in the
comments kept telling me that i
shouldn't be using the shortcut but i
don't have to [ __ ] reload it as much
as long as i'm reading that correctly
maybe i make a mistake
um it is technically more powerful but
okay vote key
get anything else in here though plenty
i'm not leaving until i get literally
all of it
so everyone enjoy this
don't need to do that
okay cool yeah good that's good you like
that
thank you bless ah love to see it
was that it no [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh there could be fish in here anybody
see any fish
i will [ __ ] them up
i'm not seeing any fish
i'd be on the map wouldn't it no fish
okay
great anything here
i need a grabby grab don't look like it
okay what else you [ __ ] go for me in
here then
gotta be something and i will not leave
without it oh is this
my okay
those armored ones damn dude
um pipe bombs really do help though okay
let's roll back to
the boat i don't think this is going to
go down this way though
i feel like maybe something prevents me
from
just strolling out to my boat friend and
jumping on in
no okay okay
cool great this is going
i didn't even see where that
[ __ ] was but now that i don't
have shotgun shells
or as many significantly less confident
where you at you stupid [ __ ] show
yourself p pansy
you're here
oh there's two of them
i love it when i get both though that is
good and i'm gonna be able to craft that
one
would need to kill you first which i
think i've done
okay shotgun ammo
please please please and then we're
crafting little one of these because we
like them
and then some more first aid
okay it's not great but it's all right
i'm gonna move this over to here
and this is
yeah okay cool
start engine because now i have a boat
key
that looks suspiciously foreign or um
modern compared to everything else in
here
all right great
oh no this is also going to overwhelm me
because there's too much choice
all right well can we get to it you [ __ ]
you
i'm gonna need to turn the windmill on
to be able to do that i guess
why do you taunt me so video game yeah
i'll be back here it's fine
it's fine alana not now don't worry
about it right now
it's a very strange first person boat
mechanics going on here
this is weird okay no
what was that it was the big fish we
read about earlier ethan you dip [ __ ]
they foreshadowed it aggressively
[ __ ] idiot
i swear too much i'm white could be it
could be a thing
okay take a sip of my cappuccino
continue onward
cool great oh oh we got pathways out
here
interesting okay
i feel like this is the right way to go
but
here i am oh it's it's
basically nice which
i would not it's for me to kill some
fish
i don't have my knife equipped that's my
bad that's very important
you know with kiss fish killing many
gamers
the one i'm best at where are you or
scamps
it says you're here somewhere your
little [ __ ]
ragamuffins show yourselves
is that red herring are there no fish in
here this isn't the content that i
signed up for
oh oh you're just sneaky
you're just a little stealth fish
get back here i'm not losing you again
it's not going down like this
oh my god is are there more
this what is so murky you know who would
have
you would have thought maybe i should be
following the noise
who the [ __ ] are you son of a [ __ ]
jump scared
okay okay get [ __ ] ass
okay great um all right
we got the fish i assume is there
something else in here
oh there it is haha sucker
you will not best me today my good sir
as long as i can reach you
by good sir large crystal
don't mind if i do all right cool i'm
feeling good feeling great how are you
so
what the hell research post or something
what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] are they doing here
daddy it'd be a shame if something
happened to you now
mm-hmm so chris why not you killed mia
it's not wrong now do me and finish the
job
you thought that i'd only first dust
over them
what's moving unknown but my guess is
we've been here too long and miranda
knows it hey
hey do you say miranda how are you
involved leave it alone
ethan you are you guys like dating or
what about the same like are you guys
definitely related to the mold the mold
is a problem yeah
i feel like we should address that did
you guys cause the mold no you're out
here with fishing it's a boys trip
oh cute stay out of our business little
boys fishing trip
oh my god are you okay
am i okay
oh my dick
that escalated quite quickly i was ready
to loot that
lab and now here i am i hope there was
nothing in it
[ __ ] stay back is that moro or just a
moro like creature
why do you assume i can't swim i don't
have time for this
well she's going to have troubles
because she's probably only got the head
of my daughter
pathetic again completely normal things
to talk about
what are you talking about the eye bits
are really bothering me
the vomit i'm all right wait i don't
mind the tentacles the [ __ ] is wrong
the eyes the little eyes oh my god
okay yeah you've been around mold for a
long time it's really bad for your lungs
you should cough that [ __ ] up you should
get rid of all of that [ __ ]
these mold is mold kills okay this is
what this is an ad for
i i just hope he's okay
great okay
great all right well um
i'm not sure what you want am i supposed
to be shooting it or
i suspect i'm supposed to be running
did i lose my only boat as well i'm not
a huge fan of that
okay oh and now you just chill
now it's all just chill all right well
sweet we're supposed to do we'll [ __ ]
figure it out ethan
okay just get your [ __ ] together [ __ ]
all you do is complain
moro's clinic let's go to this house
first
maybe he said the exit's under water
calm down with a cup of tea or something
oh my god
okay
okay okay
i thought examining this maybe would
like
make something
i'm sorry who the [ __ ] just laughed
who
the [ __ ] oh it's the duke
okay well i'll be back for you
i just oh this house is
sort of big um okay yeah cool let's open
this
real quick i can't take that
that's what i thought don't you [ __ ]
who are you kidding
all right jump in here
jump around here ah that's my weight hey
bud you wish to make a purchase yes i'm
suspecting you to have a new weapon
let me sell [ __ ] first we sell that
we sell that we sell that
didn't they get something else
didn't i get some other perfect crystal
i'm worried that i didn't pick something
up now
hopefully i had some new items i'm just
wrong i know i know you have i'm sure
that i'm gonna be really excited about
whatever it is but
let me just okay let me just do this pop
first which i have [ __ ] up terribly by
putting things in the wrong places
i can give you four fish but i can't
give you any poultry
oh that one's pretty close you're
killing me
you're killing me with the poultry [ __ ]
okay well this one's the closest so
carry on
and then what else is close-ish
let's just give you all these fish okay
king
what is it
it's nothing there's no new gun
that's what you're telling me
i'm upset i am upset
i am upset with you yes but um
i was really feeling
i guess i'll have to find it maybe
rather than have him sell it to me
which is also okay even if it's not
quite what i was looking for well i
don't need any of this [ __ ]
um so we're gonna upgrade this
these hands are more dexterous and then
this is fully upgraded so
when i sell it again i really like it
because if i keep saying rate of fire i
mean the ammo capacity is high
um
but i should get money when i sell it so
well
so you can go [ __ ] yourself is really
how i feel about this interaction please
come again
i will i'm still a big fan of your work
even if i'm upset with you right
it's not your fault supplies are
probably low
i get it you know i get it i get it
um do i want to do this right now
if i can drain the water
i'm not [ __ ] there's no power brilliant
okay i cannot
well i should check out what was outside
this way oh
oh oh oh first of all gate house
operations
damage to local aquatic life it advises
you drain all excess waters and
move the windmills with a crank
i've been looking for a crank my whole
life
pull the lever in the gate household
okay cool well we gotta find a [ __ ]
crank
should i go this way is my question
should i go this way
just kind of scope it out see what the
stitch
is no i already did that up this way
here's what i meant
just kind of you know get a feel for it
gotta see okay
oh chickens i keep
forgetting that i don't have my [ __ ]
wow this inventory is running low
[ __ ] get back you stupid [ __ ]
chickens i need poultry so bad i've
never needed poultry
more in my life give me a [ __ ] touch
get your [ __ ] ass back here
oh my god we are eating today
cool
cool is this open yet okay
that'll be all right for now my
inventory's got so much bloody space
because i've used all my [ __ ] ammo
um could we craft some no no
we will no i don't care what i'm going
to use flashbang for
why would i ever need that
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
i'm gonna try it even though i'm going
to assume that i can't crank this yet
may helps i can
no
that's what it might do seriously i
didn't suspect that that would be useful
anywhere else all right
it's high time for a jump scare
are there any lycans hanging out in
windmills these days kids
or are we all right any
anyone anybody
why'd it get quiet why did it get
quieter
you know hmm
interesting well this place is really
falling apart
somebody what a
come out here and do some maintenance
okay strange place to leave that but
i'll take it
all right this is i don't like this
because i can't see if i
am clearing things or not because it's
all outside
babe again very convenient we appreciate
you
looking good gee
yeah thank you actually helped i think
that's my bad
that's i got eaten i did just get eaten
by a fish
hey uh builds character
happened to the best you know we've all
been there it was bound to happen to
ethan eventually
i'm just surprised that he didn't get
eaten hand first um but i really thought
that it was going to jump over me for
some reason i don't know why i thought
that this fish was a [ __ ] acrobat
i suppose that i did not look into this
all right mate and then and then where
and then what is it time
yeah see it is an acrobat that's [ __ ]
up i don't i feel like i got the raw end
of the deal
all right yeah what do you how [ __ ]
deep is that was that a glitch
all right do it again
very good look at you go handsome boy
doing tricks
oh my god very cool guy
ethan ethan if you could run a little
bit more
[ __ ] hell this d i don't know why any
of us tolerate this [ __ ]
oh okay
okay okay
the odds of anyone getting through this
actually seemed
pretty low i feel like
we'd really all be quite dead um
okay uh
i'm gonna shoot at it some more or what
maybe i need the fish to like come at me
or some [ __ ]
trying to knock this thing down i'm
gonna
come knock this down bud i'm trying to
hmm
is there something else i can do to it
okay yeah i hear ya mate um yeah you're
very scary
uh i gotta go out there there's gonna be
another one to shoot i see
okay
oh it's moro
i don't know why it didn't occur to me
that it was him so this is what i'm
assuming i'm supposed to be doing yeah
correct
okay the um
i'm gonna make a house about
what house about i'm gonna make a video
about
house uh veneviento adonis house or
whatever
how you say it um this game is really
well designed
in terms of the puzzles in that you're
like okay i can't do this
what are the options it's given me i
have this ring that has blood on it
that is the only thing i have that can't
be interacted with in any other way
and i can't use it the only thing
interact with the bull in this house is
this tap um it just does a really good
job of like
letting you deduce what you're supposed
to do
am i gonna take that i just want this
[ __ ]
damn wheel so bad so bad
this does not seem safe stinks
ew
worst things have happened to his hands
though let's be honest
oh people are the unknown but upset
very upset i know so embarrass you for
your friends i'm very sorry
that's interesting i still can't get
over there right
no this is supposed to stay on okay is
it am i gonna get electrocuted
is sort of my question
no okay
all right that does not seem safe at all
and i don't feel good about any of it
beautiful
okay what's going on here
is that just to get back no surely not
oh that's right no this one
which is going to do what
over there oh interesting okay
do i have everything here doesn't tell
me um is this on a timer
hmm find out
i can't get to the orange one now oh
cause it's back here
interesting okay let's just try all of
this
i'm still not positive what that one's
doing it's my only beef
that one and then hit that one
i remember both of these [ __ ]
and then over these took some risks
there
but they made it okay but i hear you
oh no okay it's fine everything's fine
you're gonna come for me again it's
pretty hard to predict
oh my okay i feel like you have a bad
turning circle so i'm safe right now
because it should take you a long
[ __ ] time to turn around
oh look at you self-esteem is getting
better
proud of you king
okay where where else are you yelling
about being the best
buddy my guy my friend
hello okay
didn't think that was a safe move if i'm
being honest
all right here we go probably stupid
bullet it just felt
like the right thing to do yeah
sometimes
sometimes you just gotta feel it you
just got to throw a bullet away because
it feels good
that was cool that was a cool trick cool
guy
mother miranda is really doing a [ __ ]
number on these people
she really really is
in an abusive relationship with every
single one of them
um i feel like she's
toxic and uh
everyone in this town needs therapy and
that that should be addressed
i just feel like we should be talking
about that a bit more you know
cancel mother miranda hashtag mother
miranda is over party
you have [ __ ] up everyone and you need
to take some responsibility
for what you've done all right let's
shoot this
great nothing
map still has nothing
i feel like there should be loot here
but if you say if you say there's none
then that's okay that's on you go off
king
okay
i caught myself a big one [ __ ] off ethan
shut up you piece of [ __ ]
okay okay yeah it's not like i was
planning to move in
i don't know what you thought
oh my god okay
uh what is this
no it's just the same windmill
why does it feel like there's a chainsaw
onto me
oh it's a different one now okay
it's cool oh my hey
you're gonna jump up this high really
you're gonna [ __ ] jump up this high
you
you are the best you are
unrealistically good and yeah
[ __ ] crank baby um
i'd love you love to see it you [ __ ]
love to see it what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] i need to find another
piece for that
unexpected okay
oh my god there's something else i can
do here
yeah okay let's put the thing in maybe
is that what you want me to do
and then maybe i'll be able to connect
the two bits of the ladder
grab the crank you don't forget that
[ __ ] crank dude one job
that's what we're here for okay great
let's go
this really this fish
has respiratory issues i sometimes sound
like that when i'm breathing when i'm
having asper problems
and i just i just feel like it should be
addressed
that maybe the fish needs help oh
oh we can do that now
um i think he might have like sleep
apnea or something as well
and i just i just want to know if he's
has he been to a doctor is he getting
any help
really i'm just trying to look out
for him doesn't seem like anyone else is
certainly um toxic
mother miranda hashtag who is over
party all right that was actually pretty
fun
let's go see
king something in particular actually
i have some paltry to finally get rid
off
put it in the right place alana don't
[ __ ] this up
i'm gonna [ __ ] it up i'm gonna [ __ ] it
up i've messed this up so bad it's just
three pieces of poultry
oh let's just hang up give me a second
let's just [ __ ] get this [ __ ] down
here and out here
so okay i really have
hurt myself a lot can i get [ __ ] back
please let me get [ __ ] back because i
don't have one more [ __ ] meat
[ __ ] okay
this one's the closest but we need one
more meat this one needs
fish which i don't have poultry
poultry poultry
i'm going to spread it between the two
recipes so let's do that thank you
i'd love to give you that meat but i
don't [ __ ] have it because i'm an
idiot like why is there one meat in
there and two meat in there alana
well there's one meat in there yep
you stupid [ __ ] thank you [ __ ] sake
i've gotten some new stock have you
what'd you get prof what's new
i don't know if you guys just heard the
door knock but i just got a delivery
which when you're in hotel quarantine
for 14 days straight
is the most exciting thing in the world
a friend sent me a bunch of snacks
and beer australian beer
oh my god this is lovely wow
okay i will inspect that later for now
what [ __ ] new stock did you get you
piece of [ __ ]
nothing that i care about um i can sell
that for you
you can have that
no no no no no no we're not selling that
that one just that one right now
i still don't want to sell the ladies
lipstick because
it just makes me think of her you know
on those lonely nights
in the village where all you can hear is
the heavy breathing of a lichen it's
just nice to sort of
press it upon my face and know that she
exists
yeah dude these guns are going to get me
so much [ __ ] money when i start
selling them
damn but for now trust them
no i'm doing fine thank you i just had
no need for crystals i don't even know
what you do with them
and then yeah i'm fine whatever
i'll leave it all for now okay look
forward to seeing the fruits of your
exploration
well i thank you my good sir let me
continue onward
to this i think okay so it's orange
orange orange blue
blue blue how though
okay it seems too simple
anything all right video game sometimes
yeah i understand sometimes you got a
video game
and it can be very complicated
oh a power puzzle
um do you want to go more to how to move
that one though
interesting too simple i said so that
means it's flipped
that means this is blue that's orange
that's white that's blue that's white
that's orange that blue
oh my god we've done it what's happening
in my hair what's going on with this bit
you having a party over here
calm down okay just fix that
okay done
still what's happening what's happening
buddy
all right we letting this fish out and
is it a good thing
got it it's in front that's why it's
confusing
okay find the way out
seems vague
why did them
it does make sense that i'm still gonna
have to fight him
where do we suppose i'm supposed to go
to get away from him
i don't [ __ ] know
he's probably broken through something
is that what's happened and then i
follow him
through whatever new pathway he's opened
maybe
how did you hide out here dude you're
pretty big
and like significantly audible
this is the one thing about this game
that's the most confusing
how the [ __ ] is everybody so stealthy
it doesn't make sense where you get that
kind of stealth from
okay
thank you
october 1 a sunny day mother miranda
brought me like five peoples from the
village just like
i asked it i made them sleep with some
liquid and then i put
cadao in their tummies i'm looking
forward to the cadao
to grant to grow in their tummies
october 2
a cloudy day four of the people from the
village are dead this morning
one is almost a lichen i sent it to my
lab on the mountain
i failed again mother wants strong
vessels but i cannot get any
i will need more people from the village
i read it like it was a kid's book i
hope you all enjoyed that what's this
sick what's that anything else
in here yep that's gonna be it
okay
what do the yellow ropes do can i climb
now
this is going to be a blast fight for
sure
there's cover okay
hello right on key mate right on key
he's gonna be like lady d where it can
only [ __ ] kill him when he pops out
ah too close no no no no no no no no no
no
isn't that locked up before
that's confusing
okay oh my god
okay oh god oh god oh god ah
[ __ ] how am i even supposed to [ __ ]
get him
um
try that yeah
okay that's not great i don't have
enough explosives
that doesn't seem fair as a complete
stranger i don't know that
um what are you gonna do up there mate
[Music]
oh my god what the [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
jesus christ
okay so
he shoots acid rain that will kill me
ah that's what the yellow
is for that's to tell you where you can
cover
so my guess is that when i see him get
on a rooftop
i run the cover alright
try it again you big [ __ ] big
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's what i said
try me
i will [ __ ] kill you i guess i've got
to do this oh no
it's the exact same thing that happened
last time very scary when he runs at you
i'm just gonna go back to this red thing
where you like big boy are you a roof or
you want to where the [ __ ] are you
where the [ __ ] are you i did i didn't
say you were
never said that about you come on come
on mate
come on big boy are you very special you
know i know
be glitched
you are comfortable
come on come on now [ __ ] [ __ ]
you trying to get up on a rooftop right
now
i don't even know you i really don't
feel like i'm responsible for that
rooftop he's doing it let's see if this
works
i'm just gonna pull pipe bombs out i
think
just do that with some pipe bombs right
now
you do have some ammo in you
that we could maybe shortcut
there because you have more shots
i'm alright with it for now
jesus christ am i supposed to do
something while he does that no
okay
this may be more stuff for me though in
it
there is i should just keep going maybe
i can get ready
buddy hello okay there's one right here
come for it and then my large friend oh
we got bigger
oh jeez how did you like that
was that bad for you i [ __ ] that up
i wasted it and i thought that that was
my shotgun and it wasn't my shotgun
let's do that again
[ __ ] dude
[Music]
is that it
i honestly i feel like you just sort of
misunderstood and i
and for that i apologize
and death as he was in life disgusting
ethan
he just was misunderstood and needed
some love uh
now that your dad surges excuse me while
i loot your arena
don't mind me just gonna roll through
here
see if there's anything else for me to
grab
you understand you understand you're not
that important
it was really just all about the [ __ ] i
could get from you
i don't know why i keep expecting this
game to be a lot harder than it is
can't tell you why i keep expecting
these boss fights to last a lot longer
maybe maybe they were harder in
resident evil 7 maybe that's why i keep
expecting it to be the exits up ahead
okay let's go wonderful
cool great
get the [ __ ] out of here
well i don't have the key for that yet
though
but i don't have it yet i just went and
grabbed myself a bottle of water
okay
um i'm sure it is and i guess
ah this is his hiding hole
mother miranda gave me a rose jar no one
likes me which is why i thought they
would leave me out again but heisenberg
said that was why we each get a rose
the whole thing was actually like a
bachelor situation and they
misunderstood that rose is a baby maybe
these are people
okay hear me out the static on the tv
implies that they don't really get tv
signal
in this town so maybe what's happening
here is they're all misunderstood
they only ever listen to the bachelor in
audio format as like a podcast
so they think a rose ceremony is not the
flower the rose
and then they encountered a girl named
rose and they went right for it
they're just trying to make a reality tv
show
you see what i'm saying
oh oh no no never mind i
clearly misunderstood apparently mother
said rose is a vessel
with a vessel mother can get her real
child back even though she has been dead
for a very long time
no that's probably not the bachelor okay
but if mother does then what will happen
to me i'm not a real child would she
abandon me no i don't want that no no
no no these [ __ ]
she really she really putting them
through it yeah all right
that's what you've been putting in
people is that alive so what happened to
chris
also have i looted this place i haven't
my my you have something else for me
is it a [ __ ] crystal i have to shoot
or some [ __ ]
it's definitely in here whatever it is i
will find you
and you will become mine oh
oh i just didn't take this that's a
problem i thought that i did
thank you
you're better off than i thought who's
that
pokemon is that nicholas cage nothing
really matters
nick cage you're the last [ __ ] in my
way aren't you
you've got fights i'll give you that
even
but what's the plan which is definitely
nick cage
what are you trying to get at i could
lend you a hand
i'm trying to get on my good side go
don't get cocky
i'd kill you if you weren't worth the
trouble
harsh with this stronghold not too far
outside the village
go there and get my flask do that
he the thor guy first head back to the
graveyard why do you always want me to
go to the graveyard what is this [ __ ]
town
self-centered prick nice yeah you tell
him
when he hangs up ethan [ __ ] winters
dude i would really like to get to that
i can get through that now let's do all
of this all up there which way
oh i just go right here brilliant
yeah mind if i do also i might heal
okay great so
[Music]
no i need to get to whatever morrow's
hidden weapon is
and i don't think i can do the labyrinth
puzzle
all right we're gonna have to do some
[ __ ] exploring down here to figure
out how to get to
this [ __ ] oh hang on maybe back
outside
the boat situation
maybe it's open now but there won't be a
boat now
maybe i can walk to it now this wasn't
it the thing that was like right there
wasn't it like right here
wait a minute wait a minute i don't
that's maybe gonna be that is gonna be
through the mechanical door that's
through this lab area
but i think this is um
don't think this was open before
because the water changed correct the
water has changed
and now i can get thus flashbangs
anything else
anything else anything else anything
else
or is that it oh do you have some more
fish for me mayhaps
i do not have my knife equipped once
again oh it's a mess out here disgusting
i regret looking
down there
jesus
okay um oh
that's the chest i saw before
all right actually then any fish in here
anybody see i didn't even equip
my knife okay
[ __ ] ass fish is it one of those
catfish again
i've got yourself a [ __ ]
watch me dude i will [ __ ] find you
i will end you i'm having so much
trouble with this
stealthy fish thing that they've
introduced just now
i can't believe i got jump scared the
worst in this whole level by a fish
buddy there are fish in here right okay
they're off
that would have been bad hmm excuse
me that's a fish
that's fish oh i don't want to lose you
[Music]
[ __ ] i think it's um i'm also getting
reflection from the one light that's in
my room
so i'm really i should turn that off
probably
because i can't [ __ ] see
are you what like the toughest fish
that's ever existed or something
where's the other one still alive i know
it is
i [ __ ] hear you you're just all that
these are real gamer hours i'm getting
intense
why did it sound like somebody just
opened a door was it the fish
they learned how to open doors now
[ __ ] pricks done
that's on my watch i realize that i
haven't seen a goat in a really long
time
which makes me think that i'm missing
all the goats
that's what just made me think of that i
can hear one that's what the sound is
it's that grading sound
oh it's right there that that's an odd
subconscious thing that just happened to
me i wonder if i saw it out of my
peripheral vision or i heard it
and went um goat brains
this is how they work in real time um
okay
i feel content to leave
this [ __ ] show
everything is blue
except i don't have the ball for the
labyrinth puzzle which is
upstairs and that but no that's fine
that is fine
yeah that's fine um or at least i don't
think i have it
oh wait is this the wrong way you think
it is
it was back this way
okay let's go
these jump scares keep like hurting my
muscles and that one was just a fish
so maybe
27 is old you know maybe
maybe i am old and i just didn't think i
was
okay it's like my shoulder hurts because
i keep
getting everything i need to turn this
light off i'm gonna turn the light
off well i can see the game much better
but now it's so spooky
look how spooky it is um okay
is somebody maybe gonna be waiting for
me out here
because that's what it sounds like
hello somebody going to be home
that's just the machine okay
um so i don't think i have the thing for
the labyrinth puzzle yet right
yeah i didn't think so um usually i
would end here but i'm gonna keep
playing because i feel like we should
just finish this whole section
and i'm [ __ ] stoked about this crank
dude i'm like
this game has made me a crank enthusiast
i am
living my best life i'm so excited
i can't bloody believe it all right
why what was that mechanism why was that
so difficult
um can i craft anything in the meantime
how am i doing on we should grab that
nope
crafted the wrong thing but not not
actually that unhappy about it
view over here i'll move you over here
i really thought i'd get a weapon
somewhere in this area oh i guess the
the chest is going to be out this way so
maybe that'll be whatever this weapon
i'm looking for is
stupid [ __ ] crows uh still that
achievement for killing crows i need to
go for
hmm
what what oh it's the gargoyles
ah cool um all right
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know why i
pulled this out like i'd be able to do
it now all of a sudden
do not do that i need to remap that
that's i'm gonna make mistakes
this has more ammo and is technically
the one i should
hello just [ __ ] just just just come
for me
just get it over with you weird
tongue beasts
just [ __ ] all right just come at me
i don't love it okay this is actually
quite a bit of ammo
oh my god what the [ __ ] how did i not
see that
oh my god
he's trying to have a heart attack all
right
all right it's fine i really should have
seen him on the ground but i didn't
it's all right we all make mistakes can
you just [ __ ]
attack me please
just [ __ ] come for me [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ] who the [ __ ] was that you
you guys
okay are not who i'm asking to come for
me so you need to [ __ ] carve out
i don't want to waste my [ __ ] ammo on
you
you don't even deserve my bullets we'll
take the crystal skull stuff thank you
appreciate that thanks it's these
[ __ ] guys that i'm trying to
stop beef with oh yeah i know
i also i'm trying to fight
i just need you to get out of the
building
a bit okay are you
how are we gonna do what are we gonna do
about that i wonder are you in here
is that gonna work don't blow you out of
the building no you still saw it in here
but maybe
just do that
[Applause]
that was helpful actually thank you for
that that that
benefited me can the other one do that
then
you [ __ ] [ __ ] did i get more
australian since i've been in australia
even though i've not actually been
outside i'm just calling everyone [ __ ]
[ __ ]
get dead mate i'm not gonna be able to
get whatever loot you had though
[ __ ] all right all right yeah yeah
[Applause]
stay down thank you
what did you have on you
and did it fall into the house under no
no it didn't um
feels like i have a lot of options
huh
hmm well
i'm just gonna try and clear out this
area first at least
somebody's still mad at me and i can't i
don't know who it is or where they are
but they are upset
i hear you i understand you're upset
but i'm not sure i should care keeps
giving me flashbangs i wonder who i'm
supposed to use those against
all right who are you why are you upset
do we need to talk it out
has mother miranda given you self-esteem
issues as well are you up there
maybe i feel like you might be up in
this house
who are you what are you about excuse me
what is this my friend
buddy i did
not outside definitely inside okay
oh oh
oh that's interesting
okay what's your
what's your story
it's an almond one
no just a regular man
and there's another one
how did i not see where the other one
was
all right hey
that checks out not quite what i was
after
i was have expecting a bigger weapon
mother more even gave me a mountain
now i can do lots and lots of caddo
experiments if this is my secret special
laboratory i'm probably pronouncing that
word wrong every time
i did three they all went pop and made a
mess
i went in the cadao and then i tried
putting wolf blood from a needle into
the
spine the person wriggled a lot and then
killed my assistant
i wonder what um he looked like before
this all went down
also seriously who the [ __ ] is that
where are you you prick
you here somewhere is it another [ __ ]
oh
okay
okay
we'll put you here
and reload you for now
i didn't expect this
[ __ ] jump nope
ethan nope nope nope nope just ran into
a building again
i do that sometimes sometimes it happens
maybe just a shotgun for now
probably is easier than my sniper
strategy that i keep over using [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you gotta be almost dead i shouldn't
reload it there
you gotta be close all right it's not so
bad
um it certainly does help to have the uh
bloody yeah
[ __ ] yep
the launcher is what i was trying to say
in situations like this um let's go do
the labyrinth puzzle
okay is anybody gonna be back here and
try and fight me now
am i safe maybe i'm safe
all right uh this is
the
mermaid ball
cool i wonder if this one has a thing
where it can fall off like the other one
did
probably
yep
these are really cool it'd be neat if
they made them in real life
ah i didn't even realize that that was
oh there's a little hole there i didn't
see it okay
keep going this would be cool with uh
motion controls i wonder if it has that
on other
platforms onto playstation
all right let me drop you down there and
i think it does need to go through this
way but like just
very far over here through this way
yes okay
not that wonderful visually i can be
honest
but they never said labyrinths was
pretty
okay i was worried that it would have a
bit where it would have missing railing
or something
looks like it's all right all right
we've done it
thank you confetti i appreciate it
very pretty okay we've done
everything here let's
end it the way we always do
by returning to the duke in the village
saving right here and returning
to the duke in the village
maybe getting shot on the way back i
don't just [ __ ] around and find out
but now i have the mechanical thing and
i oh
oh
maybe i should wait until next time
maybe this won't be that chill
and i should wait because i could just
be walking into like more things that i
don't want to leave behind based on this
sign
so i'm gonna leave it there that's fit
for part nine everybody
i will see you all next time